hi there
so as Dave said we're always a little
bit more personable right after lunch
we're also a little bit more excitable
right after coffee so you're catching
yeah just have coffee so this talk is
about Android application architecture
I'm Adam Powell I'm on the android
framework team I meet Boyer I'm also in
the under a firmer team so this is
actually going to be a little bit of a
special extended edition version of a
talk that we gave earlier this year at
Google i/o just like every good special
edition the original version isn't
available on video so here you are so
the important thing about application
architecture is really you need to act
early in your applications as soon as
you start writing code you've made these
decisions that are going to affect how
your application is going to be
developed from there forward so those
decisions stick with you these really
really deeply influence your application
we're going to show you a few of the
ways that this really affects how you
might write your app as you move forward
it really makes it easier or harder to
think about the problems that you're
really setting to solve in your
application so you might be asking okay
well which patterns do I use there's a
lot of stuff out there and you can
really kind of get into a lot of
alphabet soup as you start looking over
all of the different prescriptive
patterns that you can blow into for I'm
super confused yeah yeah I mean I've got
all these things here that's me by doing
customers so this isn't a survey of
libraries that's not what we're here to
talk about today and there really are a
lot of great libraries out there and you
should really look into many of them and
see what they can do for you and but I
mean the trends change quickly the
challenges you're going to face are
really timeless the properties of some
of these devices that we're writing for
have been the same properties from the
first time any one of us held a
smartphone and really lava flow happens
over time this is kind of this
phenomenon where after your code goes
through a number of refactorings there
isn't really kind of an overarching
principle that ties it all together
anymore someone new who comes to your
code base may or may not understand
what's going on as you start piling up
all of these different pieces that
really no longer fit
the important takeaway from this is to
architect for user experience really
nobody in your user base is going to
care exactly what patterns you used to
produce your application they're going
to care about the experience that they
have while they've got it in their hand
alright so let's let's look at some
examples
maybe some videos so here's an
application it's very simple I'm posting
your comment on a photo trying to type
right there you go send an hour waiting
why am I waiting I have no idea I'm just
waiting waiting all right it's sent so
what was the problem here so what's
happening was the user clicks on the
send button it goes your controller goes
your network network comes out comes
back whenever it wants to come back and
then you update your UI meanwhile you
block the user because you don't know
what happened maybe the comment will not
go what did we get rid of this
introduced something you can call a
model which is your storage with where
you keep your comments and everything so
and then when the user hits the send
button you keep it in your model
updating you are they'll tell the
network that this has been added and you
can when the network on zurich you can
update you are so let's get the same
example this time with the fix how it
looks so I come here I taught my comment
in the same comment so he makes use the
same use case I send it I instantly see
the comment is little bit gray but I see
it there when the network has finally
comes back it turns black user has a
clue you can design it better I couldn't
but this idea you get you give the
feedback instantly your designers are
wonderful make sure that you appreciate
them yeah I told you why did you give me
a design job ok let's look at one more
demo ok is the same purpose I keep
commented I'll like it
I keep commenting and I hit Send
ok you can see that it's like it's
grayed out I see the response decently
they scrape it turns like best grade I
go back to that page
is empty like ours here literally two
seconds ago I came back I came back to
the page and it's not there like this is
bad this is inconsistent I feel like
something that lost so what was
happening here so the wheel the wheel
controller as we said before told the
model model told the network it came
back we updated Ti great but the problem
is the model they don't have anything
right it only is still fed by the
network what if instead you kept a
persistent model so is that your data
stays on your client your there's
something that you can always access
unless the phone crashes which you
cannot do anything in that case instead
we have some application logic that's
responsible to synchronize Network and
you're persistent model is really
important to look at this problem as a
synchronization problem rather than
making API calls that simplifies a lot
so this application logic seeks with the
network fetches whatever you wanna fetch
updates the model then just notifies
anybody okay I'm done I made some
changes hey guys if anyone's to know
about it here they are and then your
view controller goes and fetches the
data and updates the view let's say the
user clicked on the send button the view
control tells application logic I here
okay I have this comment please send it
the logic is the left is the disk that's
the first thing you have to do you
update the local storage until hey like
I updated this comment I added this coin
and you also call the network now
there's two things going on right now
while you're making the network query
the view controller gets notified okay I
have a new comment to fetch goes to
model updates di when the network
finally returns the application logical
taste model again and says ok I seek to
comment to slower
if anybody's inserted like do something
and then the view controller goes
updates to live again so every like
everybody has like very simple duties
and they are decoupled
so how it looks let me implanted
properly I come here is installed
because it's coming from the local
storage like it cannot be slow
unless something is going really bad on
my device which sometimes happens
alright sir
well my example so fun ok it's running
so I'm so excited that I keep sending
comments but I'm only seeing the first
comment I said like something is ok they
just showed up like what happened there
I don't know what happened there and I
figure out what happened there so this
was my background case I had this great
pull on the background that processes
all these things one by one so that I
don't create 2 main threats so when I
loaded the activity to like a fetch with
McJob came for the photo and the other
one to load the comments from the disk
so I had to executives they started
running meanwhile this user started
spamming my application with all these
new comments I finish it in the comments
the other one came we put the comment in
the disk and now we are trying to send
it to servers
meanwhile the network is really bad so
the fetching my job is to rank the wheel
controller get a notification about the
new comment I wanted to refresh itself
but the cure is food like I'm using and
then the job cannot run so the way is
not updating because I'm trying to fetch
a bitmap like this is bad this is where
the means the priorities are not good
but it's very hard to know right you
don't know how long the job will take
you cannot estimate it all the time but
what you can do is separate these things
so if I have a different queue for my
network tasks and a different queue from
my local tasks when my network is flaky
my application is still responsive
because they are never affected so if
you run the same jobs that we run the
previous scenario as you can see now
they are going into different threads
and the local task queue just keeps
running because disk is fine because we
could have fished a bit but we couldn't
update that we can send a comment to
server but who cares user is still
seeing it and if we make that change as
well
so you just everything is sending and as
they as it gets time to run the show
jobs you're seeing that like they're
starting to turn black from top one by
one they will eventually be synced okay
so one of one of the feedbacks we get
after lyre is like okay about how does
the activity get notified so there is
activity is a very very simple state
machine in this scenario when it is
created you set up your UI that's all
you do when you start you register for
the unit's you want to know about and
you load your data this is how it
ensures that bit me restarts or whatever
if there's some events you missed you
will never miss them because they all
start you register you refresh your data
and when an event comes just refresh
your data it's like this hitting over
all stop bound refresh your data you
just are register from events so your
life cycle is very very simple like this
happens I do this this happens I do this
this makes it easier to test much more
stable much more easier to understand
okay back to you all right so the key
takeaway from all the demo that we just
saw there was really you need to design
for offline I always assume that the
network is not your friend it's going to
be slow and if you want to deliver a
good user experience you really can't
just blame the network for why something
isn't popping in quickly the table
stakes have really been raised on this
when it comes to mobile so to solve this
back your UI with a local model and use
your other application logic to sync the
model on the server rather than doing
this as live API calls it can be really
tempting to try to optimize for the case
where you want data freshness above all
else where you really don't want to show
anything to the user unless you're
really really sure about it but this is
one of those things where if you assume
success versus assuming failure then
like what types of what types of claims
are you really making about your
software when you assume failure in the
common case I mean your software is
going to work right your server is going
to come back with the answer that you
expected right so optimize for those
case predict it show it to the user
early by their I just learned yesterday
a fancy new name called optimistic
rendering so she'll like know what is
called optimistic rendering yeah I mean
the actual thing that you see this
principle at work in a lot of other
areas of software development as well
games is one really prominent example
where a lot of network latency
compensation systems in multiplayer
games are based on this principle they
predict based on what happened in the
previous known state from the network so
you can use these same ideas in your own
apps so make sure that these things
don't necessarily depend on each other
unless it's in a very loose fashion use
event and callbacks and such when needed
to notify other parts of your system
about state that's changed so everybody
always asks us about dependency
injection as well is it good is it bad
what should I use what library should I
use well I mean who use it if it helps I
mean everything has a costs so know the
side effects of what it is that you're
doing and what it is that you're
including it's very very easy to include
a new dependency in your application and
it's not always easy to see what costs
of that are going to be at runtime
especially when you're just bench
testing at your desk everything is in
the optimal case when you're sitting
there at your desk so avoid reflection
for better performance as well many
dependency injection frameworks have a
heavy runtime component versus a compile
time component some systems like dagger
to do this at compile time and it ends
up being much more optimal for your
application so take a look into these
and see what the trade-offs are when it
comes to networking so we talked about
other things that we can do always
assume the network is going to be slow
janky always assume that you've got your
phone in the middle of a conference with
crowded Wi-Fi and completely slammed
cell towers that's basically your case
that you want to optimize for here
because this is when people are going to
notice that your application is broken
when it falls over so your API design at
the network layer can actually affect
this as well so design your back-end for
your client not the other way around and
this is one of those things that sounds
really obvious when you get up here and
say it but as you start building server
backends for these things you start
exposing pieces that you may need
and so forth and really start building
it up as a series of layers so you have
the the very low level components that
provide your data such as the network
and then you have the higher level
components that preside provide the
presentation and it's very tempting to
not have the higher levels inform the
design of the lower levels but you can
get a lot of wins by doing this also
process as much as you can on the server
side to begin with you have these big
beefy servers in the cloud that can do a
lot of work for you don't offload stuff
to the client that you don't have to
more specifically pass metadata to the
client this is something that can really
really improve your user experience if
you have a large blob of data such as a
big photo that you're going to pull down
as part of syncing some sort of social
app for example what do you know about
this image at the time that you've made
this request and gotten this response
back well not a whole lot so what are
you going to show while that loads while
you actually go fetch that image a
better case would be to pass on along a
little bit more metadata give your
application some hints that it needs to
succeed in this case we're passing the
width and height of this image in
advance before we go fetch the image
itself this allows us to perfectly sized
a placeholder in our UI so that you
don't have your UI jumping back and
forth as the user Scrolls through or
attempts to move back and forth we've
also passed along some pallet
information here just to be able to give
our UI a little bit more of a splash of
color that keeps the flavor of the image
before we actually have the real bit
battery and data this is another concern
that you've got whenever you're talking
to the network as well especially when
you're doing any sort of background
syncing
that's your requests as much as possible
now we've provided a lot of other tools
in recent versions of Android to help
you do this effectively things like doze
and marshmallow or great examples those
will do a lot of this for you but really
don't just rely on that as your sole way
of dealing with this does is essentially
the last line of defense for the user at
this point use the job scheduler when it
makes sense give Android as much
information about what it is that your
app is actually trying to do and that
way Android can make smarter decisions
about how best
optimize that the key takeaway here is
act locally
sync globally you really want to give
the user a very fast very responsive
local experience whenever they're using
your application and then make sure that
you keep that in sync with the cloud
almost as an afterthought compared with
the presentation that you're trying to
give so no talk of application
architecture would be complete without
some sort of addressing of the question
of activities and fragments this is
something that we constantly get
questions about even within Google we'll
get questions with like oh okay well
should I use activities or should I use
fragments to build my apps like well
that doesn't entirely make a whole lot
of sense the question fragments are
really just encapsulated parts of an
activity so when you build up your
application when your activity starts
getting too big and you need to start
breaking it up so you can still think
about it effectively it's a great time
to break it down into some fragments or
if you start by building single
fragments that sort of compose together
a little bit more than that so you keep
your concerns separated that can help
keep things a little bit more straight
in your head so that you don't end up
with these giant activity God classes
fragments and views is another one that
we get a lot now this is something that
we talk about quite a bit on the
framework team in terms of like one of
the almost regrets of the fragment API
at this point is that you've got this
handy little tag that you can just stick
in your layout that says fragment and
says go ahead and instantiate a fragment
and stick it right here in my layout
when I inflate it and this thing is
really really convenient it makes for
great code examples and demos because
you can do things like have a layout
that sticks to fragments side by side
and then you rotate the device and it
sticks them stacked on top of one
another and you say hey look look at
this great decoupled system that I've
got makes for a fantastic demo but
realistically this makes people think of
fragments as being view constructs
themselves and really they kind of
aren't so they live in these very
different worlds so views are really the
nuts and bolts of your UIs that you're
building
whereas activities and fragments are the
lifecycle constructs that basically
provide the plug-in points of contact
with the rest of the system that tells
you what's going on so many times you're
going to want to use both to keep these
responsive
ladies clear just as you mentioned
earlier you're going to want to use the
signals that you get from your activity
and in conjunction with that through
your fragments as well if you're using
those to basically inform when you
should register on register for events
so on and so forth but the views should
really kind of be their own encapsulated
pieces separate from that that are
controlled by these other constructs
okay so moving along to another topic of
contention often memory so this is
something that we talk about a lot if
you've watched any of colt's talks on
the Android performance practices you've
seen some of these avoid allocating
objects and hot code paths putting
pressure on the GC is not so great art
is a lot better at this these days than
Android used to be at all of this but
there's still a lot of those devices out
in the wild and if you watch this in a
few sensitive code paths then you're
going to end up with a little bit of a
smoother experience so you can pool and
reuse some objects when you measure a
problem that last part is really the key
when you measure a problem make sure
that you're measuring these things
before you go and contort the internals
of your system and these are the sorts
of things where some things you can make
some decisions early that will help you
move into these optimizations should you
need them and some things it really
doesn't matter so write the code the way
that it's clearer first and then
optimize later so GC still kind of
remains your enemy especially on some of
these older devices even as the garbage
collector in Android gets much better so
perfect example of how this may affect
your API design internally just with
smaller components now what's the
difference between these two approaches
well the top one is arguably more
idiomatic much cleaner you can make some
assumptions about it in terms of okay
well the object it returns is probably
hopefully safe if that's a mutable
object to begin with but in order for
that to be true then this getter has to
be allocating a new wrecked forming that
it returns well now we've got allocation
so where do you end up using that versus
the second form here which is basically
just taking an input parameter that the
method is going to fill out you know
that the second one isn't going to
perform
any additional allocation in this case
this is the sort of thing that you
really only want to worry about in
extremely hot code paths we're talking
layout that gets run many many times
we're talking drawing that gets run
sixty times per second if you're talking
about things that happen in terms of
your event handlers like clicks and so
on and so forth you really don't need to
be contorting your system this much
internally but for that very small
percentage of your code it is okay to
write ugly code if it helps your users
your users are not going to see your
code they're going to see your UI if
your UI is ugly because it's behaving
badly then that's something that they do
see that's something that really does
affect their experience the performance
critical code really isn't the majority
and while all compiled code looks like
we eventually anyways so with that we're
going to move over to another demo that
kind of brings a bunch of these ideas
together okay yeah
so after diode told one of the feedbacks
we received was ok you taught these
things but show me some code that's it
clear so this time we wrote a sample
application keep in mind this a sample
application and the main focus here is
how do you look at this problem with a
synchronization problem how do you
design an application to work offline
and we are going to release the source
code just waiting for some applause so
here's my application I'll just lost my
Chrome all right let's come here so so
real app like there is a real server
running on my computer it's for the
purpose of the demo and the application
is just a list of posts oh hello
everybody I can say I could say
everybody okay so how does this work so
it's this do something dangerous and
just it's not that dangerous all the
more danger like I said I just disabled
to network and I send one more so right
now like please forgive my UI but so
there is there's a upload Club on the
right bottom of text that tells the user
this is not the same as otherwise is
almost going to send it's not there yet
so if I actually look at my rails server
and my application when the network
recovers it's all eventually post it is
going to update di now some other
examples we saw in the previous time
actually we can crash the server too so
how the server is not running anymore
and so for this demo I have a like very
simple back off time but it just it will
just cry try try back off and I got my
application yeah it was created these
are my application logs here is actually
keep trying to post it because there is
Network just a service crashing and now
when I finally bring the server up oops
not like that not like that okay so I
mean it started backing off for the it
will eventually send a comment to the
server dies that it keeps me trying and
yes it did send so it's go one more case
where we do crash the server again ok
one more comment is the same oh wait it
didn't crash oh sorry I crash the logger
good alright so we crash the server this
time see if we can she works hello i'm
wrote a server that doesn't even crash
right come on we should go alright ID
should crash for the purpose of to them
all i hope your service won't crash so I
said one more comment and then I simply
go out so my emulator make crash though
it's been having some problems ok I did
go out and I am going to kill that
application I come back oops
ok so the comment is still there
it cannot update defeat but the comment
is waiting for me there
and I will just run the server screen
team actually synchronize this idea the
application doesn't care about when the
comment because sting in the disk
waiting to be uploaded there's some
other job that's taking care of the
upload but it will eventually go to
server unless I have a bank of course so
how do we how do we do take care of
these things the way it works is we have
this feed activity but by the way again
like this is a demo application track to
focus on certain things now might be
other problems with this demo
application the important takeaway is
the thing we are focusing here so this
application when you call Sun post it
simply tells the feed controller to send
the post which adds a job to the
displaced like something purchased and
they will eventually run which is
responsible to update the disk as well
as sending the post so it updates the
disk and then dispatches an event when
this is event is this page my activity
knows about this event refreshes itself
when it runs does the same thing or is
canceled it does the same thing this is
a persistent job that means is going to
be saved in the disk until exceeds or
reaches the retry limit this is OK
alright the comment is posted nice and
so another problem about synchronization
what happens if I'm offline send
comments so it's not working eventually
and I go to this website and I create a
point here I am from the web
all right so now these two states are
inconsistent right my client doesn't
know about the new one I have it and I
have a comment locally so if I enable my
network by the way normally when the
network comes back you would refresh
your feet but I'm not doing it for the
purpose of the demo so when the network
comes back is going to send the post
instantly and so is all those thing but
when you actually refresh its going to
add anyone to the correct order this is
because everything is time-stamped by
the server so until a post is sent to
the server you make a best guess
timestamp on it so for this example the
way I do it is again it may change per
your application but the way this one
does is let me open the save feature
okay so when it creates it actually
queries the model to get the best
timestamp I have this is a way to
synchronize if my client clients time is
like really really off and if the NIP
comment is not on top we have a look
really bad because I change your server
ordering by the UI ordering but that may
cause other problems so what I do here
is like I I assign a best case timestamp
locally and then we do it on later and
servers so we hit it off the network
again and again like another case
because of the persistence so I send a
post here click on a user names moves
you to the users post and it's not like
I never faced this user user feet but
the process that is everywhere in my
application because on my disk I don't
care if it is not synced or not I have a
proper model for that objects a simple
value object but it's always working and
let's say I'm in the user feet but then
recover the network it will eventually
set and the field will update to if I go
back is already updated here instantly
because like if a UI is interesting a
certain event it listens for it now you
could probably implement
a global event bus here you can probably
implant the same thing with rx or
broadcast like this is a sample
application it does this way and it
works there might be multiple ways to do
the same thing the writing might be a
better way so we'll get more fancy okay
like what if the server is crashing so
this is my real server by the way sort
of fun
the magical language so I'm going to
turn on a flag here which is going what
this will do is the server is going to
save the post but it's going to crash
afterwards so I won't be able to realize
that I could synchronize that post so
the service question now I go back here
I can say okay how I wish so the job
tries 20 times and it breaks off 250
milliseconds exponentially so it will
keep trying trying trying try me again
all right so now the server is crashing
as you can see the crash shocks it saves
the post to the disk but the client
doesn't know so client keeps the track
but what happens that your fetch feeds
post endpoint is working fine so i
refresh so the post came back I know
it's the same pause so how do I know
it's the same post this comes in to a
little bit API design but I we wanted
the full demo so I I did figure out the
same post and updated although my son
positive and never succeeded so the way
it works in this application is by
design each each element is assigned a
client ID so if you look at these
examples here
visible yeah alright so there's a user
ID and there's also client ID this
client ID is randomly generated and
unique per user per post so there's a
unique in Midas's user ID and client ID
is a unique topple you rely on the fact
that it's not going to conflict but yeah
I mean technically it can probably it
want so by doing this when I receive the
post from the server
I know that posterity exists in my disk
and I update that fun saying that okay I
sing this one I don't know what happened
to the job I don't care and then the job
knows while running when it before
trying to send the post it checks a is
this already synced so here like if you
can see the code here just loads it it's
already synchronized doesn't do any to
go like a this has been updated believes
everything's working fine so way one
more thing okay so the muscle idea here
is that like you do this works because
we look at the problem as two separate
problems one of the reason responsible
take the user interaction process the
model locally and the other one is
responsible to synchronize with the
server however it does it's not trivial
you are writing a bunch of additional
code to say it is like local client IDs
you I'd handle conflicts but it works so
let's get one more demo here this time I
will shut down the server okay so I'm
standing I'm again that excited kit I
keep sending all these messages of
course they are not going to go if I
look at here they are there they're not
going when I recover the server now the
first job is backing off it will line to
the finish meanwhile I can send mark as
you can see they are going up one by one
one by one in the correct order my
scroll position knows this works because
these jobs are running through the same
queue purple so I know that whoever came
first will they handle first so we
guarantee that they're in orders we
cannot guarantee their thumb stands
because this technically not possible
unless you want to rely on what your
client timestamp is but we rely on we
granted their orders again this is all
independent of the I it doesn't care at
all the only thing it knows is how do I
load this from the disk and how do I
send this comes to my application logic
one more example I want to go actually I
want to go through this collet so one of
the problems with this event there in
architecture is since all this is
happening
although I synchronize I qualify missing
you and or what if the timelines x times
don't match again for this demo
application the way this one works is
every single event that is important
comes with a timestamp so for example
for fetching the freedom and timestamp
is the timestamp of the oldest post so
that if someone is going to load those
ones it makes you it includes that
timestamp in the query so it lost things
afterwards that so every time the feed
activity receives an event let's say on
you entered it checks if this for my
user if this for my user just cause the
refresh rate to all this one and then
add refresh method while creating the
model it uses that timestamp or if there
is no time study it uses the top one
because you don't want to keep your
fetching things yeah that is mostly let
me see if I miss anything
yeah okay I think so we are going to
publish this code both the server side
and the client side to github as soon as
I need some clarification here and there
but and you can play with it we all be
happy to get polar casts or whatever if
you think something could be done better
and this is nice to share and like this
move on from there right sure that's it
is time for some questions
I think that we've got a microphone
floating around perhaps sir there we go
we'll really contain tests how will will
the project contain contain tests yes
yes actually does so I actually I should
have showed it so if you look at the
hobby well they may not be great tests
say I'm not a testing expert but they do
this mostly their most integration test
if you look at something more fancy for
example fetching the feet so I say we do
the slide back over to the computer
robot oh sorry
can we go back to the computer okay
thank you
so the application uses dagger this is
how I mock some of the API calls but
they see H feet enough sand sand command
that will be nice so short answer yes
yeah yeah they're here that's a very
nice test I can find okay five hundred
four hundred so it's like I mean this is
creating the job mocking the API so so
that if someone tries to send a post
return 404 by injects the test component
runs the job checks the appropriate
descent so all of one of the things is
like is not even when they some outputs
happen as you ants it's not very easy to
test them in this example I'm using in
the test application I'm using your
logging event bus that basically logs
every single event so that I can assert
on those later on yeah like there might
be different or better ways to do this
but this is something that works on we
have tests
so
hi um what's your opinion on using
custom views instead of fragments so you
don't have to deal with the fragment
quirks if you will so things like child
fragment manager or popping the back
stack when after us a save state so
again I think that those are they're
kind of unrelated just because they I
mean a fragment controls views it's not
a view itself I mean that was kind of
what we were trying to get out a little
bit earlier overall I think that a lot
of people write fragments when they
really meant to write a custom view so I
think that in in many cases see exactly
what it is that your particular chunk of
encapsulated UI needs to express and
respond to if those are events that can
be coming from some alternate component
that's kind of composing that pieces
place within the overall UI then that
speaks to it being probably a little bit
more like a view group if it's something
that really needs to respond to other
elements of the application lifecycle on
the activity lifecycle if it's doing
something like registering for events
dealing with things like that then it
may be more appropriate for a fragment
in that case but overall I think that
people tend to lean a little bit too
heavily on fragments when they think of
one particular sub segment of their UI
hi um one question I had was how do you
handle the serialization of these jobs
to disk and back out when the app dies
do you roll your own logic or do you use
something like a framework or something
uh so in for this demo application I'm
using Java key which is some library I
wrote before you can simply serialize
them you can use tape like that was
recently another talk to use tape to
serialize your stuff to make it like a
job there's a multiple solutions for
this out there is not that complex
either you can choose one of them which
fits your needs cool thanks
we've got one up front in this kind of
application would you use a sync adapter
or would you use like ASIC rest calls to
connect sir
so for the demo so one of the things we
gave examples in the slides was to
separate your local tasks from the
server tasks the way we do it is for
your eye related stuff I'm using
guessing tasks I never use it for
network only for you I stop and for
network I'm using the job queue so the
jobs don't master : to network
yeah the sync adapter is generally
useful if once you have a more
sophisticated account infrastructure and
you have some of the other machinery
that that was really kind of built
around so if it seems like you're going
through a lot of additional machinery to
work with a sync adapter then maybe
start taking a look at some more things
just like a job scheduler so on and so
forth and see if that's something that
is simpler that can still meet your
needs when you start building all these
applications with these different
versions of data models so you might
have like fetch data off the network
updates that the user has made to the
data that hasn't been actually pushed to
the database do you guys have any
classes it can help us maintain all this
application logic or any libraries that
you would suggest we use to maintain all
these four versions giving any more
suggestions or not I am sure not nothing
about versioning but they actually
remind me something I forgot in this one
of the important things in your client
is your clients consistency and the
soulmate crash which is so may also
start returning bad data so one of the
things this Clyde does is if I open a
user model let's say everything
everything save so before we save
anything we well date it and if it is
not valid for this client we just throw
it out because I don't understand maybe
the server has a bug maybe so is any
version I don't know we just if I don't
understand object I throw it out this
makes it easier for the rest of the
application to like a gift
object is that is properly filled so to
the point of dealing with the specific
data inconsistency is especially across
upgrades different server versions on
and so forth what we found when working
with a lot of teams both within Google
and external to Google is that many
times the the actual pieces of business
logic that make an app interesting tend
to differ so much between applications
that we've had a lot of difficulty
finding a one-size-fits-all solution to
just offer as like a prescription of hey
everyone go use this for dealing with
this particular problem space it is
something that you can make a lot of
assumptions based on the shape of your
data and what it is that your data is
actually representing so oftentimes you
need something a lot less complex than
some general solution that solves for
the entire world but if you've got some
ideas please track some of us down in
the halls here and we'd love to hear
about them
anyone else or okay all right well thank
you very much thank you